we've now been talking about fox news
host maria bartoromo for some time
she has gone from being a pretty good
financial reporter
um the first woman to broadcast from the
floor of the new york stock exchange
years ago
to a total trump brown-nosing sycophant
who repeats
every bogus lie promoted by trump or the
people around him
she has promoted and signal boosted
either through guests or herself
just about every absurd lie about the
2020 election
uh and now she is defiantly telling us
she will not stop maria bartiromo
erupted
on her own show yesterday and says she
will keep telling
lies she calls it the truth about the
2020 election you just have to see this
it's a profile in what i call
ignorant courage the dynamics and the
tone is of a principle than defiant
nature
where she will not be silenced but from
telling
lie after lie after lie let's take a
look at this clip
let me broaden this out and by the way
dr corey we should point out the effect
that the litigious nature
of our system has on creating restraints
on drug claims that's another major
problem but but
senator this is just one of many lies
let's take a look at the biggest lies of
all
since the democrats came up with this uh
ridiculous big lie about election
integrity
these are actually the biggest lies the
russia hoax based on a made-up dossier
okay so remember the russia hoax based
on a made-up dossier
the dossier is made up in the sense that
any document is created
she's saying the substance was made up
i've seen no evidence of that
i've seen corroboration of some elements
of the dossier
and just not yet corroboration of others
but there's no evidence that it was made
up
and of course russia hoax listen dozens
of indictments
mueller unable to clear trump on
obstruction so ridiculous
to try to take down trump an impeachment
of trump with absolutely no crimes
remember that that's that's another red
herring impeachment is a political
process
it doesn't require criminality under the
law so that's a classic red herring
attached to it the hunter biden laptop
and all of his business deals and the
money that he received
from everybody from the former moscow
mayor's wife to the
chinese uh companies tied to the chinese
communist party okay so
there's there's no lie it's the right is
upset
that it didn't the the right is upset
that unsubstantiated claims about hunter
didn't derail biden's presidency but
it's it to even have it on this list
seems strange
the origins of of cover 19 a lab leak
and the tree okay and then of course and
then she says uh so
notice she says as a as in passing
that there's been a lie about the fact
that kovid was a lab leak
we we don't know that to be true and i
like many others have said
investigate everything but let's not say
something is likely until we have reason
to believe that
by treatment i assume she's referring to
hydroxychloroquine and of course the
live air was
was from the right of course there's the
armed insurrection
armed insurrection is what nancy pelosi
keeps calling january 6 senator
how many guns were actually taken up on
that day
okay there were some guns we know that
there were some guns
since she says it was armed well by the
way
they they always talk about thousands of
armed insurrectionists
i asked the f eyewitness not one not one
gun was recovered either in the capital
or on the capitol grounds understand
that recover just means they weren't
left behind
according to that fbi witness so but
there's video of people with with
handguns that's just
one of the latest big lies um
and you know maria do we have to
understand how dangerous this is for our
democracy
everyone's concerned about her show is
dangerous for democracy russian
interference the
2016 2020 election what the big media
does
uh it is so much more influential
and interfering in our election in our
electoral process than anything
that right so johnson's filibustering
but now listen to what she says when
they go back to
or china could ever hope to accomplish
and they don't admit it they'll never
admit it
i am so incredibly proud of this team
on sunday morning futures and of working
alongside
you we have been telling every story
we've been on the right side of it
for seven years going i've been trashed
every day along the way keep trashing me
i'll keep telling the truth
a defiant and principled maria bartoromo
who has not been on the right side of
even a single issue that i can remember
and uh telling us that she will keep
telling
all of the lies what's the long game for
maria bartoromo is it that trump comes
back
because while he was president i'm sure
it was very cushy and fun for her to
have a
a a friendly president that she could
access
but what is the long game at this point
in time i have no idea
let me know if you have thoughts make
sure you're subscribed to the
second youtube channel youtube.com
slash pacman live new youtube channel
with totally different content we'll
take a quick break
and be right back if you ever feel
like you just don't have enough time to
read all the books you want to read
you have to check out one of my favorite
apps called blinkist blinkist takes
thousands of popular nonfiction books
and distills each one down into an
e-book
or audiobook that you can get through in
just 15 minutes where you're getting all
the key takeaways from the book
just imagine how you'll be able to
expand your horizons and knowledge
by being able to soak up all of the
important insights from 10 different
books
in an afternoon obviously it's perfect
for exposing yourself to a new book
you otherwise wouldn't have time for or
you can use it to revisit a book you've
already read
or use it to preview a book before you
buy the full version and read it
i recently read a brief history of time
of course by the great stephen hawking
this is a book that i have been aware of
for so long
and other things got in the way and it
was fantastic to check it out on
blinkist
blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about
8 bucks a month and you get the entire
library
but you can try it totally free and get
25
off a subscription when you go to
blinkist.com
pacman i've put the link right
underneath this video